all right y'all I love a good ambush
especially when it involves an act of
kindness as you might have seen on the
show that much Christmas y'all behind
the scenes I wanted to do something a
little different I'm going to surprise
someone who I am extremely just grateful
fond of love him and he works on the
Kelly Clarkson show basically I'm going
to write them a letter deliver it to
them in real life and read it out loud
also they have no idea this is happening
um and also the person I'm about to pick
it's gonna hate this and I love it
that's what I'm calling it ambush thank
you
[Music]
I'm riding this to my musical director
who's been working minute since after
Idol name is Jason Halbert and I
literally couldn't like my career would
not be what it is without him I tell him
this all the time I don't know that he
believes me
Jason is I mean god he's like a brother
like we well and my brother's name is
Jason my Brotherhood it's like but I
just he's like a brother to me and I was
19 on Idol and coming off that show I
had no friends out here he was actually
technically kind of stolen from Justin
Guarini cuz he was supposed to be the
band for Justin and then I found out he
was Texan and I like he needed a friend
so badly like I had no friends I don't
know anyone I was really just
overwhelmed he was just always super
supportive we got along right off the
bat we're very different musically but
also we see eye to eye so it's helpful
we're really good partners I feel like
every like singer artist kind of needs
to find their person that kind of
complements them and helps them have
their career come to fruition and he's
definitely that for me and he's like
really quiet and like humble and like
never ever takes credit and always gives
credit away he's just the coolest dude
ever so here we go
[Music]
there we go all right now I'm gonna go
read it and he's gonna be so awkward
it's gonna be great oh my god I hope I
don't get embarrassed things should have
been more funny
[Music]
yes hearing those vocals what's up Jason
okay so this is called ambush thank you
and we started it and I started with you
obviously and I hope I crack is actually
wrote something that I didn't know
but anyway it's gonna be great Jason
you're the coolest dude I've ever met
and worked with I would not be not only
the performer and today but the person I
am has a lot to do with you always
having my back listening to me and
teaching me and honestly you're the
first male presence in my life that
didn't leave and that can stand the
consistency of our friendship has made
me a better person
thank you so much for just being you
okay okay I will not I will not cry I
love this guy I tell this all the time
but clearly I would not be he's not
gonna tell anyone that but like I would
not be where I am today without him and
literally I never wrote that down before
but you are usually Wow let's get
together no I do think I was telling
them you have to find people especially
in any line of work I think like just
especially in the music industry that
someone that complements you like we're
different worlds but like we complement
each other and that's why I think we're
successful so thank you and I like
almost cry writing at a time
I'm good with emotion alright this is my
first ambush thank you tune in next time
to do I'm gonna image thank you next I
had to start with Jason because what
topped here
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this